i'm in iceland
and i am on one of the most popular
beaches in iceland but it's completely
empty
and it's midnight
but anyway i want to tell you about
something that i've learned while i'm
here
and it has to do with hot water
through a lot of dipping myself into a
lot of hot and cold
water what i found about this what i've
learned about it
is something that's probably going to
change my life let me show you
[Music]
you're in iceland
look ice cream
look at the taylor machine
it's still funny okay are we done then
let's get started
a long time ago iceland didn't exist and
then
these two plates in the middle of the
atlantic ocean moved apart
and let a bunch of magma from under the
crust come up that magma cooled
and that became an island called iceland
in other words iceland is sitting on a
literal crack in the earth's crust
from which a lot of heat and magma
vents out and it's because of this that
this
little stream behind me is super warm
i'm about to get in it by the way
it's warm because there is heat from the
earth's magma that is coming
up and making it warm
[Music]
the word saturday lugardach in icelandic
means pool day or hot spring day it's
literally a part of their language
and i've been seeing this as i traverse
this country everywhere we go
there is a pool or a hot spring they are
everywhere there are more pools per
capita in iceland
than anywhere on earth and that is
because
they love their hot water
it's not just hot springs iceland uses
the fact that it lives on a crack
between two tectonic plates to use that
heat to do a bunch of stuff
right now i'm in a greenhouse where they
use geothermal heat
to grow thousands and thousands of
kilograms of
tomatoes every year they're able to grow
all sorts of things that wouldn't
naturally grow in iceland
because they have geothermal heat that
they're able to sustainably
pipe into these greenhouses and grow a
ton of food it's pretty amazing
[Music]
real quick i want to say thank you to
betterhelp who's the sponsor of this
video
thank you betterhelp for sponsoring the
video i started therapy
about a year and a half ago and it has
changed my life it's changed the way i
think about everything and i've become a
major proponent of
therapy the reason i like better help is
because
they are dedicated to making therapy
more accessible
and affordable it's a platform where you
can connect with
licensed therapists and counselors in
everything from
family and marriage counseling to
personal counseling
these are accredited counselors who you
can connect with
not in person but over a digital
platform the cool thing about better
help is that they help you
match with the right therapist finding
the right therapist is is always a
tricky thing
and they assess your needs and assess
their
giant network of therapists and they
connect you with the right person
and if you don't like your therapist you
can immediately switch
you can even message your counselor
throughout the week and you'll get
thorough thoughtful responses which is
really cool
this service is available to clients
worldwide so it doesn't matter where you
live
this is a remote therapy service that
will never have you waiting in an
uncomfortable waiting
room or lobby ever again it is seamless
and
quick and tech savvy which i like
but really the whole point is to make
therapy more accessible
and more affordable so if you want to
get started and try out therapy
go to betterhelp.com johnny harris
that's betterhelp.com
johnny harris going to that link helps
support this channel but it also gets
you 10
off of your first month of better help
so
you can try it out for a discounted
price and see if it fits into your life
[Music]
the boys are freaking out right now
because i just told them that we are
swimming in a volcano which we kind of
are
[Music]
so yeah iceland is a place with a lot of
hot water it's become a part of their
culture
but is it just because it feels good
yeah it feels good
the answer is no it is not just because
it feels good so let's get into this
let's talk about what actually happens
to your body
when you immerse it in hot water the
first thing you have to understand is
that your body is obsessed
with one temperature 37 degrees celsius
or
98.6 fahrenheit your body wants to stay
at that temperature especially in your
core vital organs your brain your heart
your liver your lungs it has to keep it
at that temperature if it goes a few
degrees
above or below you're dead and your body
has one really
important mechanism for keeping itself
cool when it's too hot outside
or hot when it's too cold outside and
that very important mechanism is blood
so let's say you jump into super hot
water 40 degrees celsius 104 degrees
fahrenheit your body freaks out a little
bit it's like whoa
whoa this ambient temperature is way
hotter than what
we are used to and what we want so it
immediately gets to work
cooling yourself down and it uses blood
to do this it says get all of the blood
out of the center of the body where all
the important organs are send them out
to the extremities
let the fingers and the legs and the
calf muscles get hot don't let the heart
get hot
so your heart pumps and your blood
vessels start pulsing a little bit to
push that blood
out into different parts of your body
your blood vessels literally
open up to allow this to happen like
they like open up to make it easier for
the blood to get
the hell out of the heart and out to the
extremities
and it works it works really wonderfully
and honestly it feels
really good
[Music]
if you dip your body in hot water
regularly you
are giving the body a chance to push
blood out to all of these places that
don't
get a lot of blood most of the time mix
that with the fact that these hot
springs are usually loaded with minerals
that
are really good for the body and as you
soak in them you absorb them
and that helps your body too so it's no
surprise to me that
not only iceland but all sorts of
cultures all around the world
have discovered that soaking in hot
water is
a good thing
[Music]
water break ready to get some water
since we're in an rv we don't have tap
water
and no one sells water in iceland they
don't sell
just natural water because every time i
ask they're like you don't need to
buy water just go get water from
anywhere so we've made it a habit
to just come down to whatever river or
creek
or stream we see to fill our bottles
yes please
pretty delicious huh
okay but this gets juicier when i've
been going to some of these hot springs
i've noticed that in the corner there's
always like a bucket
of cold icy water we're going in the
freezing cold
at first i was like why on earth would
they have this and at this relaxing hot
spring and they have a bucket of cold
water
so i decided to dive into this
[Music]
okay we've talked enough about hot water
and we all love hot water and we know it
feels good
i think it's time to flip the script a
little bit and talk about the other side
of this whole thing which is the part
that i'm
literally dreading
let's do this that's really cold water
wow that was adrenaline that waterfall
is so
intense oh okay so i feel like i've been
asleep all day and now i've just woken
up like i've like
i just see everything in its true color
for the first time
[Music]
freaking love iceland
okay so remember that when you go into
hot water your body
kind of freaks out and it uses all of
these little tubes and the muscles
in your arteries and veins to pump
blood out to your extremities to keep
your heart cold when you go into cold
water
the exact opposite happens your body
still freaks out
it's like we're going to die because we
are now freezing
it prepares to save the most important
parts of your body it's like don't care
about the arms at this point we don't
care about the toes
get the blood out of all of those places
bring them back to the heart and the
brain and the liver and the lungs keep
those alive and warm
so now all of your little tubes are
flexing and pulsing and
pushing all of this blood back to the
center of your body
and here's the deal your veins and
arteries don't
get to do this very often especially in
our modern age where we're like cozy all
the time
they don't have a lot of practice
pushing blood out to the extremities
when
everything's hot and then pushing it all
back to the heart
when everything is cold this is sort of
like lifting weights for your
cardiovascular system
you're giving your circulation system a
chance
to work out in a way that it never
really has the opportunity to do when
you're like sitting around cozy all the
time in your nice warm clothes and nice
warm house
[Music]
it's freaking gorgeous boys look at this
all right let's go explore glacier
i know this is sort of trendy right now
cold showers
cold baths whatever like this is
something that is definitely catching on
and the leader of a lot of this is this
guy named wim hof
he's like a dutch ice man he has all
these world records for holding his
breath and like
running marathons in the arctic circle
just in shorts and he's barefoot and all
this stuff
i gotta be honest i've been very
skeptical of wim hof and his followers
because
he sort of has this guru vibe going on
where he's like this wild crazy
character and like
he has this wild new method that's gonna
solve your world yes
however i started looking into study
after study
after study after study about cold water
and what it does to our bodies and i
have to say
despite my deep skepticism of wim hof as
the guru and his followers as just
another sort of like trendy new age
wellness business
i'm convinced
[Music]
it turns out that the benefit of going
into cold water
is actually incredibly well documented
through
randomized control studies that have
nothing to do with wim hof
they studied people who go swimming in
ice water in
finland and found that these people are
way stronger more resilient less prone
to
anxiety depression their bodies function
more effectively
and the craziest part the one that blows
my mind is they discovered that when you
go into cold water
your body actually creates more white
blood cells the defense
cells that help with your immunity so
people who dip in cold water actually
have stronger immune systems
there's absolutely something to this and
as i've scrutinized it and looked into
it and done it myself
i've learned that it's actually pretty
compelling and something that i feel
like i'm probably going to
start doing more and more in my life the
data is there
it's real it is very compelling and
here's the deal
as i've been here in iceland i've been
experimenting with this i've been going
into cold water
it's been horrendous but it's been
amazing there's this feeling you get
when you come out of it where you're
just like in this euphoria
freaking love iceland so my little
adventure into
hot water into natural hot springs
into cold water has been really
interesting
not just because it feels good but
because it has
really amazing health benefits that
people caught onto
and that's why they made it a part of
their culture because it helps people
live better
[Music]
you